tens of thousands of students are not
allowed to go back to school until next
month as a highly contagious virus
spreads in Colorado it shut down an
entire school district in the Grand
Junction area that southwest of Denver
and forced a major cleaning effort there
and we're learning that a second school
district is also closing because of the
norovirus Omar Villafranca went to Grand
Junction the other day to show us why
some patients are getting sick twice I
have three kids and they'd like to share
germs with three preteens at home joy
Zeller says the district-wide school
shutdown is inconvenient but necessary
we definitely don't want to be sick for
Thanksgiving and the way that this virus
seems to be working it's it's kind of
like one person gets sick in the family
and then a couple days go by and then
another person gets sick 46 schools in
the Grand Junction district are closing
until after the Thanksgiving break
impacting 22,000 students after a
suspected outbreak of norovirus it's a
highly contagious bug that causes
diarrhea vomiting and stomach cramps
those particles get in the air and then
if you're near there you breathe the air
in you're sick and you've been exposed
the virus survives for weeks on surfaces
like desks doorknobs or toys if not
properly disinfected sanitation crews
are now cleaning the surface areas of
every school in the district the
cleaning process is with bleach because
that is the only thing that's really
effective against this virus according
to the Health Department hundreds of
students and dozens of staff members
have fallen ill district officials
believe there's now a second related
strain of the virus as well so you had
students and staff that were getting
sick not once but twice and that tells
us we're losing the battle for CBS this
morning
Omar Villafranca Grand Junction Colorado
I hope they do win that battle in the
end Thank You Omar